THEY DON'T WIN.
>> LET'S BUTTON THIS THING UP,
SHALL WE?
LET'S BRING IN OUR BOY CHRIS
SIMMS, OUR NEW TEAMMATE, OUR
QUARTERBACK.
HOW YOU DOING?
>> I'M DOING GOOD, MAN.
THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>> GOOD, NO, APPRECIATE YOU.
YOU KNOW WHO IS NOT DOING WELL
UNFORTUNATELY THROUGH NO FAULT
OF HIS OWN, JARROD TAYLOR.
YOU CANNOT LOSE YOUR JOB TO
INJURY, THAT'S -- WHOEVER SAID
THAT IS WRONG.
IT HAPPENS ALL THE TIME.
THIS IS UNUSUAL.
CRACKED RIBS, PAINKILLER
INJECTION BEFORE THE GAME,
PUNCTURED A LUNG, THAT'S WHY HE
WAS A LATE SCRATCH, JUSTIN
HERBERT SIXTH OVERALL PICK
LOOKED FANTASTIC.
HARD TO BELIEVE THAT THE
ORGANIZATION WOULD GO BACK FROM
HERBERT, BUT THAT'S -- I HATE TO
USE THIS WORD.
LIFE AIN'T FAIR, THAT'S REAL
UNFAIR, ISN'T IT?
>> IT IS ABOUT AS UNFAIR AS IT
GETS.
IT IS.
FIRST OFF I DO FEEL BAD FOR
TYROD TAYLOR.
IT WAS TWO YEARS AGO, RIGHT,
HE'S PLAYING FOR THE CLEVELAND
BROWNS, HURTS HIS WRIST IN THE
SAME STORY HAPPENS.
BAKER MAYFIELD COMES IN, WE GO,
WHOA, HE LOOKS KIND OF GOOD.
HE'S A ROOKIE, BUT LET'S START
PLAYING THEM.
THEN GOT TO PLAY IN BUFFALO,
WENT TO THE PLAYOFFS.
HE'S BEEN VERY UNLUCKY,
UNDERAPPRECIATED, ALL THOSE
TYPES OF THINGS, AND THIS IS ONE
WHERE I DON'T EVEN KNOW HOW TO
EXPLAIN IT, YOU KNOW THAT IS A
TRICKY AREA THERE IN THE RIBS,
HE WANTS TO PLAY, HE'S TOUGH,
I'M SURE THE DOCTOR WHO I DON'T
THINK IS INTENTIONALLY TRYING TO
HURT HIM, I MEAN, HE'S A GOOD
GUY, HE'S JUST TRYING TO GET IT
IN THERE TO WHERE TYROD CAN
THROW AND FEEL COMFORTABLE.
BUT OBVIOUSLY THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN
AND NOW YOU HAVE THE CAROLINA
PANTHERS VERSUS THE CHARGERS
THIS WEEKEND AND HERBERT, AS YOU
MENTIONED, LOOKED REALLY GOOD
LAST WEEK.
HE'S GOT THE HIGHEST CEILING,
GUYS, OUT OF ALL OF THE
QUARTERBACKS THAT CAME OUT IN
THE LAST DRAFT.
HE'S GOT SOME FREAKISH ABILITY
AS YOU SAW.
CAROLINA'S DEFENSE IS NOT THAT
GOOD.
I WOULD EXPECT HIM TO PLAY
PRETTY WELL.
AND THEN THE OWNER AND GM STEP
INTO THE SITUATION AND GO, WAIT,
WE DRAFTED THIS GUY NUMBER SIX,
HE LOOKS PRETTY GOOD, LET'S
START THE FUTURE AND START GOING
THERE.
>> WELL, I WANT TO ASK ABOUT
THAT COMMENT ABOUT HERBERT
HAVING THE HIGHEST CEILING.
BRING GET
BEFORE I GET THERE, GAME
SITUATION, ANTHONY LIND DEFENDED
HIMSELF, GIVING IT UP ON FOURTH
AND ONE.
WANTED TO GIVE HIMS TEAM ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY.
YOU GOT TO BE AGGRESSIVE AN GO
FOR IT.
HOW DID YOU SEE IT?
>> THAT'S ONE OF THOSE THERE,
I'M NOT ALWAYS FOR THE
AGGRESSIVE MOVE, GO FOR THE
AGGRESSIVE MOVE.
YOU PLAY KANSAS CITY, THIS IS
WHERE ANALYTICS ARE DIFFERENT.
IT IS NOT ALWAYS, YOU KNOW, OH,
THE NUMBERS SAY DO THIS, I'LL DO
IT, YOU GOT TO TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
WHAT IS ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE
FIELD.
DO THE ANALYTICS, LIKE, DO THEY
HAVE A FORMULA THAT CAN SAY,
WHOA, THIS IS THE CLUTCHEST GUY
IN FOOTBALL ON THE OTHER SIDE,
HE CAN MAKE MAGIC HAPPEN?
NO, PROBABLY NOT.
THE THING THAT ANTHONY LYNN I
THINK PROBABLY SAW KANSAS CITY
STRUGGLES MOVING THE BALL
AGAINST US ALL DAY LONG.
I THINK MY DEFENSE CAN MAKE ONE
MORE STOP.
BUT AS WE HAVE SEEN, YOU DON'T
DO THAT AGAINST PATRICK MAHOMES.
I DID NOT AGREE WITH THAT
DECISION.
I PROBABLY WOULD HAVE GONE FOR
IT, YOU'RE RIGHT, PUSHED THE
ISSUE.
I'M SICK OF ANALYTICS ALL OVER
FOOTBALL, THOUGH.
I'LL TELL YOU THAT MUCH.
>> YOU MENTIONED THAT HERBERT
HAS THE HIGHEST CEILING.
AND I'M THINKING ABOUT TUA
TAGOVAILOA, I LOVE THAT PICK FOR
MIAMI.
I LOVED HIM IN COLLEGE.
HE USED TO GET BANGED UP A LOT.
THAT'S NOT A GOOD THING FOR A
QUARTERBACK, YOU TELL ME.
BUT I WOULD SAY IT IS HIM.
WHY WOULD YOU PICK HERBERT OVER
TUA?
>> RIGHT, WELL, JOE BURROW IS
AMAZING.
BURROW WAS THE MOST GAME READY,
READY TO GO, I MADE HIM MY
NUMBER ONE QUARTERBACK IN THIS
CLASS.
BUT HERBERT HAD THINGS YOU SAW
IN THE EVALUATION PROCESS YOU
WENT, LIKE, WHOA, LOOK AT THIS
BIG DUDE RUNNING DOWN THE
SIDELINE.
RUNNING AWAY FROM DBs.
LAST WEEK HE RAN OVER A
LINEBACKER AND CONCUSSED HIM.
THEN HE HAS AN ARM THAT TRULY IS
SPECIAL.
I KNOW YOU GUYS SAW SOME OF THE
GAME LAST WEEK, HE MADE A FEW
THROWS IN THE GAME WHERE THE
DEFENDERS WERE, LIKE, WHOA, I
CAN'T BELIEVE YOU GOT THAT IN
THERE.
WE THOUGHT ONLY AN OLD GUY OR
AARON RODGERS COULD DO THAT.
HE CAME FROM OREGON, A BASIC RAW
OFFENSE, HE'S GOT ROOM TO GROW
THAT WAY.
TUA, ON THE OTHER HAND, MR.
HOLLEY, ALL RIGHT, I WAS NOT THE
BIGGEST FAN OF HIM COMING OUT.
HE WAS MY THIRD RATED
QUARTERBACK.
I LIKE HIM, DON'T GET ME WRONG.
YOU MENTIONED IT, SIZE ISSUES,
OVERRATED ATHLETICISM, HE'S GOOD
IN THE POCKET, CAN BOUNCE
AROUND, BUT MADE VERY FEW NFL
THROWS WHEN PEOPLE WERE AROUND
HIM.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO JUST, YOU
KNOW, ALSO SAY, HE HAD, YOU
KNOW, TWO OFFENSIVE FIRST ROUND
TACKLES, FOUR FIRST ROUND WIDE
RECEIVERS, AND UNBELIEVABLE
OFFENSE.
AND THAT OFFENSE DIDN'T MISS A
BEAT WHEN HE CAME OUT.
SO I THINK HE WAS A LITTLE BIT
MORE OVERRATED IN MY OPINION,
HOLLEY, THAN JUST THE FACT I
THINK HE WAS A PIECE OF A GREAT
MACHINE WHICH IS ALABAMA.
I'M NOT SURE HOW GREAT -- I'LL
BET YOU A BURGER ON IT OR
SOMETHING.
>> OKAY.
SO, YOU KNOW WHAT, TUA, WE DON'T
EXPECT HIM TO PLAY, HE'S NOT
STARTING YET, I WANT TO TALK TO
YOU ABOUT MY JACKSONVILLE
JAGUARS.
>> OH.
>> THAT'S MY SQUAD.
THAT'S THE NERD IN ME TALKING.
THAT'S THE GENERAL MANAGER THAT
I'VE ALWAYS WANTED TO BE, THAT'S
MY DREAM TALKING WITH THE TEAM
THAT HAS GOT 11 DRAFT PICKS, IN
THIS YEAR'S DRAFT, AFTER HAVING
A BIG ONE IN THE LAST DRAFT, I
WOULD HAVE LIQUIDATED THE
ROSTER.
BUT THEN YOU TURN AROUND AND,
NO, THIS IS THE PLANT.
YOU WIN WEEK ONE AGAINST
HOUSTON.
THEY HAD A MORAL VICTORY.
I'M ABOUT A MORAL VICTORY WITH
THIS TEAM BECAUSE I WAS -- I WAS
TANKING FOR TREVOR.
BUT I'LL BE DAMNED -- NOW YOU
GOT THE BEST OF BOTH WORLDS, YOU
GOT YOUR QUARTERBACK, NOW TAKE
THE TWO FIRST ROUNDERS AND GO
THE REST OF YOUR TEAM.
HOW DO YOU SEE THAT FRANCHISE
FUTURE?
>> I THINK IT COULD -- I THINK
YOU EXPLAINED IT PRETTY WELL.
I AM A BELIEVER IN GARDNER
MINCHU.
HE HAS MOXIE, CHARISMA,
PLAYMAKING ABILITY WHEN THE
OFFENSE DOESN'T DELIVER.
HE HAS A GREAT ABILITY TO MOVE
AROUND THE POCKET, DANCE, GET
OUT OF THE POCKET, MAKE A PLAY
THAT WAY.
WHEN THERE ARE PLAYS TO BE HAD,
HE DOESN'T MISS IT.
HE TAKES ADVANTAGE OF ALL THAT'S
THERE.
I'M WITH YOU.
AND THEY'RE KIND OF REBUILDING
ON THE FLY.
THERE IS A LOT OF YOUNG TALENTED
GUYS ON THAT TEAM RIGHT NOW THAT
I LIKE.
AND IF THIS CONTINUES, WHAT WE
SAW, I KNOW THEY'RE 1-1, THEY
DIDN'T REALLY DESERVE TO BEAT
THE COLTS WEEK ONE, BUT, YOU
KNOW, REGARDLESS, THEY LOOKED
VERY GOOD IN BOTH GAMES WHERE
YOU GO, THEY'RE BETTER THAN I
THOUGHT.
IF HE CONTINUES TO PLAY LIKE
THIS, YES, SORRY, THEY GOT TO
MOVE ON FROM THE TREVOR LAWRENCE
CONVERSATION AND START JUST
BUILDING AROUND GARDNER MINCHU
AND BE THE TEAM TO BE THE BEST
TEAM POSSIBLE.
YOU DON'T ALWAYS NEED THE
GREATEST QUARTERBACK IN THE
HISTORY OF THE PLANET TO WIN
FOOTBALL GAMES, GO TO THE
PLAYOFFS AND WIN A SUPER BOWL.
WE DISCUSSED THAT THIS PAST
WEEK.
PHIL SIMMS HAD THE GIANTS AND
THE GIANTS D, HE WON A SUPER
BOWL BECAUSE OF THAT AND RUNNING
GAME AND HE MADE SOME THROWS.
DAN MARINO DIDN'T GET THAT.
HE SZOTT ZERO SUPER BOWLS AND IT
IS ABOUT THE TEAM, WE LOST SIGHT
OF THAT NOW.
IT IS ABOUT ONE GUY CONSTANTLY.
>> YOU MENTIONED PHIL SIMMS.
ONE THING PHIL SIMMS KNOWS
ABOUT, HE KNOWS ABOUT BILL
BELICHICK AND BILL BELICHICK
FASHION, AND BILL BELICHICK
QUIRKS.
SO DOES CHRIS SIMMS.
HE DID NOT LOOK GOOD YESTERDAY,
CHRIS.
I JUST GOT TO TELL YOU.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT WAS GOING ON
THERE.
BUT YOU'VE BEEN AROUND --
MICHAEL SMITH SAID IT YESTERDAY,
BILL BELICHICK JUST GIVES ZERO
Fs ABOUT ANYTHING.
HE JUST DOESN'T CARE.
HERE IT IS.
THIS IS WHO I AM.
TAKE IT OR LEAVE IT.
YOU LEAVE IT, I DON'T CARE.
I'M SURE YOU HAVE SEEN -- I'M
SURE YOU'VE SEEN AND WITNESSED
THAT SIDE OF BILL BELICHICK.
GIVE US SOME OF YOUR
OBSERVATIONS OVER THE YEARS OF
BILL DOING HIS OWN THING.
>> YEAH, HE DOES HIS OWN THING.
HE GIVES ZERO Fs AS WHAT MICHAEL
SMITH IS SAYING.
NO DOUBT ABOUT THAT.
HE'S PAST THE POINT OF TRYING TO
BE CHARISMATIC, YOU KNOW, WITH
THE MEDIA OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
IT IS A FAR CRY FROM HIS DAYS
WHEN HE WAS LIKE THE COACH OF
THE JETS FOR ONE DAY.
YOU ROLL BACK AND WATCH THAT,
AND NOW HE'S WON SIX SUPER BOWLS
AND HE'S, LIKE, I CAN WEAR
ANYTHING TO A PRESS CONFERENCE,
THIS DOESN'T MATTER.
HE'S THE ULTIMATE CURMUDGEON.
HE REALLY IS.
IF YOU MADE ME BET, THEY GOT OFF
THE PLANE FROM SEATTLE, AND THAT
COACHING STAFF WENT RIGHT TO THE
OFFICE, NEVER WENT HOME, DIDN'T
SLEEP, HE PROBABLY SLEPT AT THE
OFFICE THAT NEXT NIGHT, AND HE
JUST SAID THE HELL WITH DOING MY
HAIR OR TRYING TO LOOK GOOD FOR
A PRESS CONFERENCE, THAT'S NOT
GOING TO HAPPEN.
HE'S THE KIND OF GUY THAT IS SO
DEEP IN THOUGHT AND SO IN
ANOTHER WORLD, I ALWAYS SAY,
LIKE, IF HE WAS ON OSWALT, HEWAL
HE WOULD BE RUNNING WALL STREET,
HE WOULD BE THE WOLF.
IT WOULD BE ME AND HIM ALONE
GOING DOWN THE HALLWAY AT 9:00
AT NIGHT AND I WOULD BE A LITTLE
NERVOUS BECAUSE I'M, LIKE, GOSH,
HERE COMES COACH BELICHICK AND
HE WOULD BE WALKING AND THINKING
AND I WOULD BE, HEY, COACH, HE
WOULD LOOK UP AND, LIKE, HE HAD
NO IDEA I WAS WALKING THERE NEXT
TO HIM.
HE WAS SO DEEP IN THOUGHT,
THINKING ABOUT GAME PLAN, WHAT
HE WAS GOING TO DO HEY, CHRIS,
LIKE, I DIDN'T EVEN SEE YOU
THERE.
BUT THAT'S THE WAY HE IS, AND,
YEAH, YOU'RE RIGHT, HE DOESN'T
CARE ABOUT ANYTHING ELSE EXCEPT
WINNING AND THAT FOOTBALL TEAM.
>> SO MY LAST THING FOR YOU,
CHRIS, CAN'T LET YOU GO, WITHOUT
TALKING ABOUT A GAME OF THE
WEEK, MAYBE THE GAME OF THE
YEAR.
IT MAY NOT BE THE BEST GAME, AND
IT IS VERY EARLY IN THE SEASON,
WEEK THREE.
BUT I THINK IT IS THE HIGHEST
STAKES GAME OF THE YEAR.
THE PATRIOTS WILL BE THERE AT
THE END AS BILL LIKES TO SAY.
IF THE QUARTERBACKS STAY
HEALTHY, KANSAS CITY AND
BALTIMORE, WHO DO YOU LIKE IN
THAT GAME?
I FEEL LIKE IT WILL COME BACK TO
BITE LOSER IN THE PLAYOFFS IN
GENERAL.
WHO DO YOU LIKE IN.
>> ESPECIALLY THIS YEAR WHEN YOU
GET ONE TEAM THAT GETS THE FIRST
ROUND BYE BECAUSE OF THE PLAYOFF
FORMAT.
IT IS EVEN MORE IMPORTANT.
I ALWAYS WENT INTO IN THE LAST
FEW YEARS GOING, KANSAS CITY
MATCHES UP REALLY WELL WITH THE
BALTIMORE RAVENS.
STEVE SPAGNOLO, THE THINGS HE'LL
DO ON DEFENSE, HE'S SO SMART,
HE'S CREATIVE, KANSAS CITY DOES
HAVE SOME BIG PEOPLE IN THE
MIDDLE OF THEIR DEFENSE TO WHERE
I ALWAYS FELT LIKE THEY CAN SLOW
DOWN THAT LAMAR JACKSON HIGH
OCTANE RUN ATTACK.
AND THEN WITH BALTIMORE BEING SO
AGGRESSIVE ON THE DEFENSIVE
SIDE, MARCUS PETERS AND MARLIN
HUMPHREY IN YOUR FACE AND WE'LL
PLAY BUMP AND RUN AND BLITZ, I
THOUGHT THAT PLAYED INTO THE
HANDS OF MAHOMES AND THE CHIEFS.
BUT, THERE IS A LITTLE BIT OF
DIFFERENCE THIS YEAR.
AND I'M RIDING WITH THE RAVENS
IN THIS ONE AND I WOULDN'T HAVE
LAST YEAR.
THE RAVENS, I THINK THE BIG
THING IS THIS, LAMAR JACKSON
GOOD THING THEY DIDN'T MOVE HIM
TO RECEIVER, OKAY.
THAT'S WHAT I'M GOING TO SAY.
HE IS -- HE IS THE MAN.
HE'S ALMOST UNSTOPPABLE AT THIS
POINT.
WITH HIS ABILITY TO RUN, AND WE
CONTINUE TO SEE THE POLISH OF
THE PASSER AND HIM MAKING PLAYS
THAT WAY, AND NOW THEY HAVE THE
EMERGENCE OF THE HOLLYWOOD BROWN
AND FEW OTHER RECEIVERS THAT ARE
DEPENDABLE IN THE PASS GAME, I
DON'T SEE HOW KANSAS CITY BEATS
BALTIMORE ON MONDAY NIGHT.
NOT WITH CALAIS CAMPBELL AND
MARCUS PETERS ON THE TEAM NOW,
AND SOME OTHER YOUNG LINEBACKERS
WHO ARE IMPRESSIVE, I THINK
BALTIMORE IS, YOU KNOW, CLOSED
THAT GAP AND IS BETTER THAN
KANSAS CITY.
>> AND MICHAEL HOLLEY PLACES HIS
BET RIGHT NOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> CHRIS SIMMS, I'M TAKING YOUR
WORD FOR IT.
I APPRECIATE YOU, MAN.
ALWAYS GOOD TO SEE YOU.
BY THE WAY, LET'S NOT BET A
BURGER, LET'S BET A STEAK.
>> I'M DOWN FOR THAT.
YEAH, OKAY.
GOOD STEAK.
I'LL TAKE THAT.
THANKS FOR HAVING ME, GUYS.
I'LL SEE YOU NEXT WEEK, I HOPE.
I THINK I'M COMING BACK.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> LET'S MAKE THIS A REGULAR